prize-winning columnist and author of
the new
lessons of Lucy the simple joys of an
old happy dog day Barry hey Barry how
are you you look great how old are you
now day hundreds of you know I'm 71
you don't look look at that hair no
wrinkles what's at Florida you live in
Florida that's more yeah Wow so your
book I mean I have to tell you this is
the second guest we've had on in a month
what a book addressed to their dog where
you're talking to your dog what does
that say about our society that people
are talking about their dogs in their
books books about dogs sell fairly well
probably okay and and being 70 but what
is that like because I'm years from that
and I want to know I want to well I let
me just say this I don't care what else
the medical profession does but they
need to find a way to get to the
prostate gland other than the way
they're getting to it now
[Applause]
I want to I want a procedure where the
doctor stands like 85 yards away it goes
looks good from here Dave you know you
know what I mean I've heard the rumors
it's always the last thing the doctor
does yes like it's like you don't want
it he doesn't you're both kind of
ruining that there'll be a nuclear war
and so you won't have to do that you
know right you know yours is okay
mine's good thanks how's your briefing
before the show so I I really know lucky
you don't have to know that we have some
other things you have other way are you
saying women don't have prostate no
don't know yeah for whatever it does I
don't even know what it but I use just
not to just really it's what we're going
to talk about but I got even close to
anything nothing but you know they used
to say if you lost it nothing you would
lose it you know they'd take it out you
couldn't have sex but I hear now they
have a way to you can lose it and still
have sex with a woman do you have a
bucket list Dave do you have anything on
your bucket list no that you're pissed
now that I've been on this show no I'm a
you're good nothing you never come on
there must have been something well or
we like me I I've said in my last
special I had no buck I thought when you
I turned six I thought you get a bucket
list and I found out that everything I
haven't done I could give a [ __ ]
yeah I could give us some yeah now
really I was a reason I never went
skiing I don't want to get it no I don't
really nothing I'm good thanks for
asking
okay and I have to say ageism I feel
like is the last prejudice that you're
allowed to hold in this country but uh
okay I'm old I'm 71 and so I can argue I
can talk about this from the perspective
but you've got Pete Rose's hair well we
could trade no I mean III as an old
person I talked to groups sometimes with
all people in it and I think the thing
is we're still everybody gets old is
there like no group that doesn't turn
out escape you alternative right and so
so you're like basically talking about
something every Asian experience and if
you're old you know it sucks you know
yeah you're not gonna pretend because
it's a prostate thing the way it's one I
don't think that's the direction you go
in okay but I just mean like we I've
heard people say about Joe Joe Biden
whatever you think about his scandal and
remember I've heard people say he's just
too old and you just you know I couldn't
say nor would I want to about mayor Pete
he's too gay or yeah yeah yeah court man
or you know well he's too black I mean
you just can't say that but you can but
but you can't but you somehow can say
he's too old and that's what sensible
pressure getting really close you know
inevitably even Joe Biden is going to
die yes but it doesn't look like it's
tomorrow or anytime soon and people are
different at different eyes some people
I mean you do not look 71 I'm not just
blowing smoke up your prostate I mean it
you don't look 71 I know people who are
50 who look worse than you
you're really obsessing over that oh
yeah no really I mean it depends people
how you live depends
but but and I've also saw your bug you
write about how the younger generation
are too sensitive which of course we
started to talk about here tonight and I
think it and when you say that you're
not a dirty guy you know it's funny but
what's happened is when when people make
jokes now there's a large segment of the
race significant segment population that
doesn't even begin to enjoy it as humor
they're not right they're like they're
looking for a reason to get offended or
if they're not offended they know
somebody who would be offended or should
be offended you know so they're really
just already parsing it for you know
what what's wrong with it
without ever considering whether it's
funnier and they're Democrats on Twitter
apparently yeah
you